nouveau numéro de reporter il y a un an
et demi le 1er février 2021 l'armée
birmane reprenait le pouvoir mettant fin
brutalement à une parenthèse
démocratique d'une décennie en quelques
mois des milliers de civils vont être
tués des milliers d'autres jetés en
prison alors qu'un gouvernement de
l'ombre se forme rapidement la
résistance armée s'organise dans un pays
coupé du monde est entré en autarcie
avec nous cyril payen bonjour vous êtes
rendu cyril dans les zones frontalières
où se trouve aujourd'hui la rébellion
birman on va découvrir ce reportage dans
un instant pouvez vous nous expliquer
dans quelles circonstances et dans
quelles conditions vous avez pu réaliser
ce tournage sur les débats par essence
sont des conditions difficiles puisqu'on
est clandestin or dans un pays
complètement rentré en autarcie et qui
vous le disiez après le 1er février 2021
a pu profiter je parle de la junte
militaire de la duc de l'aco vide et du
fait que toute cette région soient
fermées au monde pendant deux ans on n'a
pas pu se rendre du tout en asie donc
des conditions compliquées on voit cette
guérilla qui se bat tous ces mouvements
de résistance qui s'organise dans les
zones où on est rentrés effectivement
clandestinement puisque les journalistes
évidemment ne sont pas les bienvenues en
bien manier alors on va découvrir votre
reportage avec des documents et des
interviews inédites de dissidents et de
d'anciens militaires on verra d'ailleurs
que la russie heroes qui joue un rôle
important on découvre votre reportage
tourné avec or anne charrier et fabrice
viejo
[Musique]
début de saison des pluies 2022 dans la
6e brigade de la rébellion karen quelque
part dans le sud est de la birmanie
séjour d'alliance entre factions rivales
bonjour à tous
je voudrais remercier salaunes d'avoir
pris la décision de nous rejoindre ce
matin
c'est une alliance historique comprenez
le bien nous voilà désormais réunis
comme des frères des frères d'âme
nous les carènes désormais unis nous
pouvons nous battre ensemble pour la
liberté pour la liberté de notre nation
ensemble pour la victoire
[Musique]
les principaux soutiens de la tatmadaw
l'armée birmane viennent de russie et de
chine
avec la guerre en ukraine nous savons
que les russes ont de grosses
difficultés
donc nous espérons qu'ils vont noir mais
nos ennemis
en tout cas moins qu'avant ils nous
bombardent avec leurs avions de chasse
nous faisons face à beaucoup de tirs de
missiles de roquettes
il frappe aussi les populations civiles
mais nous avons déjà quelques parades de
nous avons compris leur tactique nous ne
sommes pas inquiets
je suis heureux d'être de retour dans
l'organisation mère notre devoir est
d'être ensemble pour écraser les
militaires birmans ces dictateurs
birmans qui oppresse notre population
jeunes vieux femmes nous sommes des
campagnes et des villes ces résistants
pro démocratiques sont venus de toute la
birmanie pour rejoindre des rébellions
ethniques
je suis fier d'être là ce que fait la
junte c'est horrible je ne pouvais pas
rester sans rien faire je me battrai
jusqu'au bout
et il y a aussi ses prises de guerre
comme ce soda birman qui a déserté de
son bataillon pour venir en aide aux
insurgés vous savez j'ai vu trop
d'injustices je ne pouvais pas rester un
jour de plus dans cet art né je ne
m'inquiète pas pour ma famille au pays
ils ont été intimidés au début mais
maintenant ça va moi j'apporte surtout
mon expertise militaire à mes camarades
nous allons vaincre
vers la wii ware
[Musique]
cela fait un an et demi que la birmanie
a rebasculé dans la terreur le 1er
février 2021 le putsch du général
minhang linga fait renouer le pays avec
ses vieux démons dictatoriaux
mettant un terme sanglant à une
parenthèse démocratique de dix ans des
milliers de morts des centaines de
milliers de déplacés
quinze mille prisonniers politiques
mais une résistance aussi sur tous les
fronts qui s'organise et tient tête au
pouvoir birman
ces jeunes gens sont tous des étudiants
qui ont choisi de se battre ils ont fui
dans la jungle pour rejoindre l'armée
clandestine des forces de défense
populaires
je me suis préparé à mourir pour mon
pays je veux combattre les militaires
amis je veux les tuer avant à quai
oui
[Musique]
quelque part plus au sud dans l'état
karen de birmanie
on ne sait jamais quand même
et surtout les
détails rien qu'on
s'assure que cet abri et et pacifique
c'est triste en même temps de venir dans
la saison depuis cette série c'est
impossible elle a passé il ya trois
semaines et
jack et ses villages
rennais c'est vous sur tous les fronts
les récents bombardements de l'aviation
birmanes ont fait des ravages dans cette
région
ce missionnaire catholique prend tous
les risques pour aider les populations
civiles les premières victimes des
combats
[Musique]
dans ces villages en première ligne les
habitants sont prises en étau dans les
affrontements tous sont des déplacés
internes le
collégien surtout des jeunes qui avait
même cessé mais c'est tout cette année
les intentions c'est à michael
elle dormait
[Musique]
qui viennent sur la toile
en fait ce matin c'est 50% du village
qui est revenu
il y à 20 % on ne sait pas où ils sont
en fait le problème pour nous c'est
qu'il y a les rebelles karen à droite
d'autres rebelles karen à gauche et
l'armée birmane par on a toujours peur
car on est accusé d'être de mèche avec
eux il y a toujours des représailles
contre les villages c'est pour cela que
les gens fuient cela fait des mois que
l'on vit comme ça
[Musique]
une fois encore la birmanie en guerre
civile s'est repliée sur elle-même
tous les accès au pays sont fermées
de l'autre côté de la frontière la
thaïlande est devenu le sanctuaire de
milliers de réfugiés politiques
traqué par le pouvoir militaire
[Musique]
en fait je voulais d'abord obtenir mon
diplôme et puis mon idée était de mener
une vie normale
mais là tout a changé
moha 23 ans depuis plusieurs mois elle
vit clandestinement dans une bourgade de
la frontière thaïlandaise
elle est la voix et le visage d'une des
télévisions de positions les plus suivis
de birmanie une télévision qui
fonctionne avec les moyens du bord
il fait très chaud je crois que je suis
un peu nerveuse aujourd'hui
yahoo et
radio sur les paris
[Musique]
ils sont une quinzaine de journalistes
et d'activistes à vivre dans cette
maison
un endroit secret dont ils ne sortent
jamais
ça c'est le symbole de notre révolution
je les fais tatouer le 3 février trois
jours après le coup
vous pouvez lire ne jamais oublier ne
jamais pardonner c'est simple
oui c'est certain je m'ennuie un peu ici
car nous sommes loin de chez nous dans
un pays étranger et puis nous sommes
enfermés ici
quand j'étais en birmanie je sortais je
voyais du monde maintenant c'est terminé
alors je me concentre sur mon travail
mais c'est difficile d'être ici la
clandestinité c'est dur on ne sait pas
ce qui va se passer
comme je suis obligé de montrer mon
visage en public je suis constamment
inquiète pour ma famille qui est restée
en birmanie pour leur sécurité
je vis avec la peur de représailles
contre eux je crains que l'armée fasse
le lien et les retrouve nous prenons
tous beaucoup de risque ici mais ce qui
nous fait le plus peur c'est la sécurité
de nos proches restés au pays
[Musique]
quelques mois après le coup d'état des
parlementaires entré en dissidence ont
formé un gouvernement de l'ombre un
pouvoir parallèle avec des diplomates et
des ministres
tous ont été condamnés à mort en
birmanie
quand vous voyez le sacrifice de notre
population nous n'avons pas le soutien
que nous méritons la population birmane
est prête à aller jusqu'au bout elle se
bat elle meurt pour la démocratie pour
un avenir démocratique en birmanie
nous exhortons donc la communauté
internationale les nations démocratiques
à venir nous aider ils devraient nous
venir en aide ils doivent nous venir en
aide
sans aide extérieure donc la surrection
s'organise pourtant coûte que coûte et
marque des points
multipliant les coups de force contre le
régime est de plus en plus de soldats
déserte nous allons rencontrer l'un
d'eux dans un lieu secret sur la
frontière
tout ce que nous avons en haute
technologie militaire en birmanie s'est
envoyé par la russie et tout le reste
des armements y du matériel est pourvue
par la chine en ce qui concerne la
sécurité de nos dirigeants le soutien
vient de la corée du nord et parfois
aussi du pakistan pour la technologie
basique mais les avions de chasse les
missiles et les radars et surtout les
nouveaux systèmes de surveillance de
l'internet et du téléphone
tout vient exclusivement de l'armée
russe
personnellement je suis convaincue que
sans le soutien technique aériens russes
notre armée serait déjà vaincu
les généraux birmans pensait renversé le
gouvernement élu et asseoir leur pouvoir
pari perdu le peuple résiste alors que
la birmanie tragiquement s'enfonce dans
la guerre civile
[Musique]
et on se retrouve avec cyril payen de
retour de birmanie cyril on a le
sentiment en voyant votre reportage
qu'on était un moment de bascule et que
la résistance s'organise au point que
les choses pourraient évoluer
effectivement basculement c'est le mot
c'est difficile de savoir en quels
rapports de force on a aujourd'hui en
tout cas ce qu'attendait la junte
militaire je rappelle que c'est un pays
qui a été mis à genoux pendant soixante
dix ans d'une succession de junte
militaire le les généraux putschistes
s'attendait vraiment à ce que cette
génération z qui a incarné l'ailé de la
petite décennie de parenthèse
démocratique et bien de ce ne ne
résisterait pas ne se battra pas eh bien
c'est complètement le contraire qui se
passe et c'est vrai qu'un an et demi
après non seulement le voit dans le
sujet il ya un gouvernement de l'ombre
mais il ya aussi ces forces populaires
de défense et cela ce sont des jeunes
gens qui viennent des villes qui
viennent des campagnes tout est mélangé
est résolu à se battre on sent vraiment
qu'il ya une volonté d'en découdre avec
l'armée birmane qui est très très très
farouche à ses skis se retient de ceux
de ce voyage de la part de la population
germann le problème c'est qu'ils n'ont
pas des d'extérieur on n'est pas du tout
dans le cerneau le scénario ukrainien
sur un plan plus en plus de politiques
au conseil de sécurité toute forme de
sanction est bloqué par la chine et par
la russie et la russie on l'a vu aussi
grand soutien alors les rebelles
espèrent que l'ukraine va aspirer un peu
toute forme de velléités d'aller plus
loin dans le soutien militaire des russo
aux birmans mais en matière de soutien
aérien notamment la formation des avions
de chasse d'un énorme problème pour les
gens qui résident dans les zones
ethniques donc c'est certainement un
tournant mais là la bière manière
résolument en guerre civile en tout cas
pour l'instant voyez on suivra les
développements de cette actualité
birmane sur les antennes de france 24
merci beaucoup cyril payen c'est la fin
de ce magazine merci de l'avoir suivi et
on se retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un nouveau deux reporters
[Musique]